Hussam Muhammad Al-Attar from the northern Gaza Strip in
Newton City, Palestine. During the war crisis, we
did not have electricity. I thought I would go to a
place, so I went to the market. I took the dynamo and came in.
I bought one for something. I became a thousand dynamos. You found it
going electric, a thousand, and going electric. I rode the
first one up, and I went and got it.  I
also installed fans on it until it
became a problem and my hand became a good problem, and I had
wires connected to it several times during the night and times during the
day. Everything that was in the air, everything that was in the store,
and I wish that if there was a battery to store it, it would be
available for 24 hours.  My brother,
two young twins, used to wake up at night when they
found a dark room. They started shouting, so when I
mentioned this is his job. They wake up at night and
see the light. They go back to sleep and are not afraid. I
mean, we have no forbidden things or anything. I mean, at night we
sleep on the floor. We came walking from the north to Rafah.
We did not carry anything.  Other than the awareness that we are wearing,
the sound of flying at night means it is very annoying, and it
scares the little ones. I mean, just like I am afraid of the sound of flying at
night, also the military boats are in the
sea all night, as if the
sea is next to us and they are attacking, so we are
very afraid of them. There are many people who think they are in a sector.
Gaza, but this work means it is folded with them and no one has
seen it at the request of the world and all the
Arab countries to stop this war and to complete
my talent and others also to complete the talent that I
wish I could dream
of.